to Cody
I thought you're gonna sit on it love
the trail guys
if you're listening by the way Walid got
me like a ball attached to a string that
goes around your head
and you slam the ball on your nuts
what is this now
oh holy [ __ ] they got me one of the
Trump nfts no they did it dude did they
actually well it's a fake one oh god
well no it's a real it's a real life one
right only you can print that out now
exactly that's cool this isn't a fake
nft
or is it you know what I'm saying no no
it's real it's certified no but yeah
yeah
look at that
and these are going for like a pretty
penny yeah literally yeah all right
these are from Brooke and Connor okay
I'm going in here oh nice dude get your
own
you put this in your ass what do you do
with this
it's one of the fidget toys but it's a
lobster that's clever that is cute that
is really clever
oh
and then I'll just rip his nap
anytime I get my hands on anything
lobster themes
I'm surprised you did that
was that easy
you see this is this is the part where
Cody's brain took over he had to scatter
it into a hundred pieces
damn that was [ __ ] I mean that was fun
thanks
is that it no this is there's more yeah
thank you Brooke and Connor sorry that
we just uh killed there's something
about this piece that's really
captivating to me
all right because I want to light it on
fire yeah this is oh here's one from
Walid to you okay thank you
ah there's gonna be a lot of cleanup
Christmas is stupid
Christmas is what Christmas is stupid
what the hell is that
the ultimate ball holder
just put your nuts in it I guess so
for what reason oh oh it's for golf
balls oh oh
they just supposed to rest your second
is this a joke
it looks like it's a holder for your
sack pull it up let the people see not
your sack but don't do a Ludwig
like it looks like a scrotum yeah 100
percent
but it's a ball holder
let me see where your golf balls
yeah try
nah I think
you know you you put this on and then
you put on the stroke trainer yeah
this is awesome I'm definitely gonna
hang this on my bag this is oh this is
to both of us
okay it's from the troll voice
feels heavy
foreign
please make unboxing video complaint
will be processed
huh
can I see
can I see the Box yeah just gonna unbox
it real please make unboxing video
complaint will be processed
okay okay I'm gonna make an unboxing
video what is up guys today we are
unboxing this package from
okay
oh hell yeah dude what is it
commemorative 911 blocks oh they're
candles oh you can light them both on
fire
and they they're like they're in the
shape of the tower oh my God
do we have a lighter
can I see
oh
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is happening
[Music]
feel says
[Music]
sing that [ __ ]
[Music]
shut up
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up dude it's me now damn
[Applause]
it's something really good about that
song that was that was so good you guys
I actually have a gift
these are so [ __ ] up these are
extremely [ __ ] up that's why we should
light them but you know what's funny is
that they don't actually burn down yeah
they just burn at the top yeah yeah you
need the airplane to take them down
all right we got a couple more
damn that that was crazy
yeah I did [ __ ] awesome yeah I loved
that can we get him back in here
I love that
all right this is let's just get him in
here every 10 minutes and let's do a
different one oh wait you're not the
only one with a trump in it what
wow I got the boxing one yours is so
much cooler
damn dude I thought I was special
nah dude oh is this actually what they
look like
that's crazy guys we have a gift from
Candace
Candace you slide devil
for us
show the people
laughs
this is a candle from the candle Daddy
and the scent is both of these nuts
thank you Candace Zach definitely didn't
send this one
yeah nice nice
actually actually
no it smells fine
let me smell
right
yeah
[Laughter]
so ew dude you're way too much
it smells like this ball holder yeah
sometimes I want a light on fire and
then pour the wax into that
okay it smells like duck butter
okay this is for me this is from Santa
everything's for me dude damn [ __ ] I'm
too busy anyways
[Laughter]
I'm too busy with my cat oh is this is
this a waste call
the [ __ ] is this
deer pong what oh it's weird pong but
you just hit a deer why was that only to
him
that's the coolest [ __ ] gifts thus
far this is definitely for both of us
it's a mistake I think we gotta play
that dude no it's what's dope as you
hang it on the wall and the [ __ ]
antlers hold the cup so sick
Cody's frad boy is about to go insane
can we finish the podcast